>> Now you saw that it's pretty complicated to calculate the standard deviation,
but what's so great about it? Why don't we just find the average absolute
deviation? Why do we have to square each deviation, find the average square, and
then take the square root? Doesn't it seem like a lot of extra complicated
steps? Well actually, the standard deviation is really cool, and it helps us a
lot when we do statistical analysis. It turns out that with a normal
distribution, and if you remember, that's where the mean equals the median
equals the mode, right in the center of the distribution, which is symmetrical,
the standard deviation has great properties. Approximately 68 percent of the
data falls within 1 standard deviation of the mean. So here's 1 standard
deviation on each side, and I'm using the lower case sigma to represent standard
deviation. So 68 percent of the data falls between this value, which is x bar
minus 1 standard deviation, and this value, which is x bar plus 1 standard
deviation. And 95 percent of the data falls within 2 standard deviations. So
this value here is x bar, the mean, plus 2 standard deviations, and this value
is x bar minus 2 standard deviations. So 95 percent of the data will be between
this value and this value. In fact, we can approximate how much data will lie in
between any number of standard deviations from the mean. We know this because
some poor mathematician calculated this for us and put it all into a really nice
table. We're going to use this table a lot in the course, but not yet.